three posts a day to the best of your
ability the other thing that people do
wrong with what i just said is they'll
post once every three days that's like
that's like doing a push-up and thinking
you're doing good health and wellness
the good news with tick-tock is it's
completely based on interest so you can
post something that gets 14 views and
the next one might get 47 000. so
because you're
succumbing to the algorithm get out of
your own head like don't worry about
anything literally besides making it
you're not going to be right you're not
going to be right anyway so you almost
have to go through like almost think of
it this way 500 posts before you're
allowed to think what's going to work
you don't like being on camera because
you feel self-conscious you don't like
how your voice sounds you don't like you
can hack around everything like a lot of
people who follow me they think they
have to be so high energy i'm like no no
you have to be yourself
hi hey gary how you doing
i am well hey brit hey joe
welcome hi everybody thank you brittany
for everything uh appreciate it so much
and uh we're gonna get started here for
you here because i know you're you're
pretty busy and we
wanna get this uh plugged in um so let's
do a quick little uh round robin we'll
go around the the room i'm gonna
introduce you to gary give quick 30
second high level just vital signs of
you and your company then we'll come
back around we'll spotlight you and you
can have your time with gary so we're
going to start out in vancouver be gary
with inga von olak who is working at one
of the biggest brands in the world but
she's here to really unlock her personal
brand so inga say hi to gary
oh hi gary
hi how are you
great i'm super excited session's been
really great um yeah i'm here to
start working on my personal brand and
you know i've made a ton of money for
other people in my life and uh ready to
ready to get myself out there
that's awesome
there you go and sticking in the great
white north we've got a guy that's
operating in one of your favorite spaces
gary he is a serial entrepreneur but he
also owns a winery up there
in
bc doug bell say hi to gary
hey gary uh great to be here thanks so
much for dropping in and um yeah this is
a second generation entrepreneur i took
over my family group of companies uh 14
years ago
when i was 22
and i have had the fortune of growing
that business quite a bit
and now we're just kind of looking at
getting into you know new businesses
building existing businesses and we have
canada's largest fruit winery uh which i
uh constructed in 2015. so a bit of a
different concept and looking forward to
chatting about it awesome man obviously
feel very comfortable in that combo
uh another convo you'll probably feel
pretty comfortable with is uh i'm gonna
draw out the accent a little bit because
we're gonna go down to birmingham
alabama and say hi to jennifer carlson
who owns a slew of uh restaurants and
different brands now in that area jc say
hi
hey gary super happy to be here today my
husband i on a polished fast casual
restaurant we have two locations right
now getting ready to open a third one
this um spring and we also have a coffee
concept here in birmingham we're looking
to grow and scale our brand and that's
why we're here
awesome thanks for being here
yeah and over to virginia we've got uh
garrett wilhelm garrett say hi to gary
what's up gary thank you so much for
this opportunity and time i know your
your time is valuable i own early
education schools child cares in the
area i saw a gap in the education system
and not preparing our kids for the
actual future
and knowing that permanent learning is
done in infancy to six six years old i
decided that this case that i was going
to attack and so
i have two brands the ohana school and
creative gardens and i'm growing a
network of schools across the country
very cool i like it a lot thank you
next up we have doug and brennan who are
in the nft space uh doug brennan go
ahead and say hi to gary
hi doug um my partner
hi gary my partner
it's still nice to say hi to doug
talk to him for a couple hours
um yes so my partner doug and i based in
philadelphia long-time real estate
investors
newly hotel owners boutique hotel owners
and about to dip our toe into the nft
space
very cool pleased to meet you nice to
meet you doug how are you
i'm doing great doing great i
first met you 10 years ago at yanyx
underground event so uh good to uh be
with you again and as brandon said we're
getting ready to launch nft um around
women empowerment
very cool
and if you're interested in taking your
kids gary up to connecticut to see some
goats we've got aaron and elizabeth
simon who own one of the uh
awesome uh company up in connecticut
i'll let them explain a little more to
you and carrie i would invite you to
come see goats any day you are a true
goat in my mind um
you might remember me i did a couple
activations with vayner sports with our
barbecue sauce brand back in the day
and now we've created a substantial
community about 30 000 strong and my
wife makes super fancy high-end goat
milk soap now and we loved all
e-commerce and we just opened our own
retail store here on the farm
i love it you also look remarkably cozy
which is putting me in a good mood
we're good good that's how we do it
so super premium goat milk soap yeah i
have some here if you want to see it
when we get to it we actually i think
what makes us really unique too is that
you can watch the ghosts 24 7 on our
youtube channel love it and you can
watch them from conception to birth and
be loved so smart so we teach everybody
about like yup how do we find
the care that goes into our product and
everything it's really good i love it
i'm super into these kind of businesses
okay awesome
and then lastly we have uh neha and
brian up in toronto they're essentially
like a cross between like a james orsini
because they're both cpas but they know
a lot about dtc e-commerce and they run
a grocery store up there so neha and
brian say hi
hi gary
i'm reading your book every night right
now so i love the exercises
congratulations thank you anything
anything stand out so far
uh
yeah just the exercises because a lot of
the concepts you talk about are really
here and what stood out to me was that
and then the other thing was the story
about the woman who started a blueberry
jam
i love it with her kid right
and forgiving herself
yeah i'm really glad you attached to
that one
i uh for everybody who's not reading the
book i did a bunch of scenarios to kind
of like re i feel like i do best and
trying to make my point in a story
and the one that is uh referring to
really got me like it's such a classic
female
entrepreneur email that i get you know
it's what's great is i'm just listening
all the time so that scenario is the
combination of
at this point maybe 10 000 emails or
direct messages from women in detail of
like what they go through in that
scenario and i'm really glad you
attached to it ironically i just tweeted
a piece of data
from people doing the exercises or
tweeting about the book
it's really very funny actually it's um
it's based on the first 739 tweets of
people talking about what their
weaknesses are
here's the best one this is like so meta
the one that has the least responses to
what their weaknesses
is humility
which in itself is the meta of the whole
thing like only 16 of 739 people said
their core weakness is humility which is
the whole punchline of the whole thing
anyway nonetheless go ahead
um so
i'm neha i run switch grocery and we're
an online retail store gary in canada we
find food brands uh faster than
traditional grocery stores so find food
brands bring them to canadians ship
across canada
uh we're a highly social company and
i'll turn it over to my co-founder brian
brian how are you
hi gary good how are you doing well
um i don't have a time to add beyond
what neha said uh as joe said we're neha
are also both cpas accountants
so there's that so you're the map
the math of the company is strong
the math of the company is strong and
somehow ne has also learned the social
marketing i'm not there yet yep i only
joined full-time four months ago so i
haven't got there but
yeah we're back right when you talk
about fight like you're just finding
emerging brands quicker
high quality emerging brands quicker so
you have some competitive advantage of
like whether it's exclusivity or just
storytelling blah blah blah
exclusivity a lot of the time exactly
you're getting you're you're making
you're making deals where whether how
much you buy or the fact that you're
just expanding to the market you're
getting a 6 or 12 month head start
a lot of the us brands don't want to
deal with canadian
customs all that so we have we deal with
all that and then as a result they give
us
some of them were on like third fourth
year exclusivity because they see no
reason to change good for you very cool
all right
rock and roll
yes yeah i'm gonna go flip it first over
to inga
and uh we're gonna go with her uh so
inga let me just just to remind
everybody you know obviously you've been
go through the day this is the time to
get very very narrow and very very
selfish like what is your actual
question
everybody will find ironically value
from each other but um please
fire away
anger you're up
thanks hey gary so i um
i was just talking to brittany about
this but i'm i'm really kind of
struggling to figure out how to separate
my day job
from
like all the other personal branding
things that i
you know wanted to do you're um when you
were talking for some reason my
headphones weren't working super well i
caught the tail end but i was going to
ask you up front what is the job again
remind me
uh so i work for tesla um
in operations
and
i
you know i like i haven't really done
anything on social because i've been
with tesla for almost five years and you
know we're under very strict ndas and
yes um you know i just it just like i
just couldn't figure out how to talk
about
and why do you want to and why do you
want to make personal brand content
because i feel like i have a lot to say
i have a lot to give i have a lot to
do that without disclosing where you
work
or without or without referencing
anything and talking in general
totally it's just that my main platform
is on linkedin and that's where i have a
current a bit of a base um i have an
invite and is the company giving you any
headaches for putting out content
uh no not yet i haven't really like i
said i haven't i i just went on linkedin
in 2015 and i i knew that i
you know
wanted to build something in the future
and i started building up a network and
i you know i have 30 000 followers which
is not a lot but it's a lot not nothing
but i haven't been engaging them and i
feel like that's sort of my place that's
very incredible and and i apologize for
interrupting because i just want to get
you as much value as possible what what
was why did you sign up for this what is
the kpi what would you like to happen
i ultimately would like to
like deliver value to people who
struggle with the things that i see
people struggle with all the time
um and ultimately monetize got it and
how would you like to monetize
at least as a hypothesis right now
i i mean i guess i would like to like
provide provide training materials
provide um
so is your is your hope to
so you're in a pickle where you want to
build personal brand to monetize
but you'd like to do that while you're
still getting paid by tesla but you're
half pregnant because you can only go so
far because you work at tesla yeah
yes
yes so in this scenario i think there's
a couple of things to think about one
you can start building brand
on tick tock believe it or not
without any reference
to
tesla or tesla in your bio and there's a
huge white space for every business on
here right now on tick tock and all of
you are going to blow it i don't know
what else to say that's the word i'm
going to use
organic reaches through the moon
30 and 40 year olds are on the platform
at scale you can literally post one
video and many more people will buy your
fruit wine or buy your you know ketchup
that you're exclusive in canada to or
sign up for your nursery school like
everybody here
is grossly underestimating how much they
can do on tick tock because tick tock is
now instagram from seven years ago but
you're gonna wait another three years
before you treat it that way
like the little rant i just made right
now
for
74 seconds
is a hundred percent
a massive roi to what you spent on this
program if you actually listened to me
and do something about it
so so for you you're in a really tough
spot because you can either save money
and like cut down your cost of living so
that you can buy yourself an entire 18
months to not work at tesla and go all
in
or
you can
go ham on something like tick tock which
is a blessing because
there's not a lot of places where you
can grow that fast and do these you know
if you look at what's going on on tick
tock right now
most of you in the world 24 months ago
were like well i'm not gonna dance on
there so what am i doing here right and
if you look carefully there's some crazy
content being produced on the platform
right now asmr type cooking stuff um
just like educational stuff like it's
really happening and gary i shared with
her the uh example of miss excel earlier
who's
got a million followers she never puts
her facebook camera it's just excel too
that's right so you know i think for you
really specifically if you're gonna do
it while you're employed at tesla it's
gonna be tick-tock
the other option is to stop spending
money for two years on anything but food
and shelter so that you can save it
and you can then give yourself two years
to then like right because that's the
other and by the way you might have won
the lotto or made great investments and
you can do that now but but
you've got to recognize that
you can't
you can't change reality and the reality
is
you know this you're playing this weird
game where like if you get successful at
it then they're going to see it and
that's going to be the problem yeah
yeah just caught in this like vicious
game
yeah and the pro i guess part of the
problem is that i
um i actually like really love my job
and i i love my awesome and and i i
don't i am in complete position
quite my job i never have to work again
okay so then i understood so that you
know five years of tesla is a good move
uh you know i think uh you know
there's a left field one
you might want to really go inside
yourself and find out if you so for
example for me right
i'm an entrepreneur but
boy do i have a lot of guidance
counselor you know reverend uh
psychologist you know you might be able
to scratch your emotional itch by
helping people not in the subject matter
of business
and
like ops
well my my whole other thing is like
around personal finance and
um
i it's not something i do at all for my
work but i'm not really good at it
that gets that gets really interesting
to me because then you can have your
cake and eat it too
okay so that's what i need to do i just
need to i would do it on tick-tock hard
because a
it will work b the quicker you can help
the youngsters that stumble on it
the biggest that's the thing people
especially women have like no clue and
they get left behind
i always hear this especially women
especially minorities i always say this
to my good friends i'm like the amount
of white men that have no idea how to
manage their [ __ ] money is
extraordinary
so let's not like kid ourselves like
every like the world the reason is from
0 to 18 back to our good friend garrett
here the world is broken
the education system of the world is
broken how the [ __ ] did i go through 18
years of school and not learn anything
about basic money management yeah brutal
like absolutely i think you should go
ham on instagram excuse me untick to all
of them but tick tock specifically on
this subject matter will dominate and
there's a lot of people out there on it
but i have a funny feeling you could do
well just by spending a few seconds even
with you
amazing thank you so much that's really
helpful
it will work out
yeah
so we're going to go three times three
times a day to the best of your ability
three posts a day to the best of your
ability the other thing that people will
do wrong with what i just said is
they'll post once every three days
that's like that's like doing a push-up
and thinking you're doing good health
and wellness
yeah
yeah i gotta get out of my own head it's
my problem the good news with tick-tock
is it's completely based on interest so
you can post something that gets 14
views and the next one might get 47 000.
so because you're succumbing to the
algorithm get out of your own head like
don't worry about anything literally
besides making it
you're not going to be you're not going
to be right anyway
like you don't have enough experience to
be right of what's going to work so you
almost have to go through like
almost think of it this way 500 posts
before you're allowed to think what's
going to work
okay that's helpful and back to his
point again other things that a lot of
you might be thinking through you don't
like being on camera because you feel
self-conscious you don't like how your
voice sounds you don't like you can hack
around everything
okay i love it
like a lot of people who follow me they
think they have to be so high energy i'm
like no no you have to be yourself
everybody like the 15 years on the
internet is very clear all versions work
pretty not pretty high energy low energy
uh monotone high pit like all of it
works it comes down to
do you know what you're talking about
and do you know the platform that you're
producing on so what you need to do is
now go consume a ton of tick-tock
information content to then get a sense
okay doing it thanks gary you got it
all right bell you are up sir
i like the i like the cpa data real
quick in the chat
and that the math was run
go ahead yeah yeah thanks so much gary
uh just a bit of uh preamble for you um
so northern lights winery is my brand uh
we're canada's largest fruit winery
started about six years ago
family company family group of companies
and we're a super niche
brand and that we obviously are making
wines from things other than grapes so
cranberry strawberry rhubarb blueberry
you name it blackberry all that kind of
stuff
and because we're in such a niche market
there's a lot of education but you know
we're not trying to sell the people who
don't want to be sold to we really want
to kind of focus and find our consumers
within our area we've been extremely
successful because we have built this
really nice community of people within
um
uh our region that really kind of know
us and love us
but as we're getting further and further
away it's kind of harder to connect with
people in that same manner um so we're
not able to kind of grow as fast as we
get further away from our home base of
course they're very they're very
different businesses one's a local
business one's a scaled brand play
that's right so i mean we're kind of in
an interesting place because we're
struggling with the need to create the
community and brand awareness um with
also our desire to grow
um to become one of the more well-known
brands and really create experiences for
people across the country um and uh so
in that we're always getting this push
and pull of how much do we time do we
spend branding and how much time do we
spend on sales
uh and how do we kind of balance that so
that's kind of my first question
well
our
push and pull with whom you yourself in
the mirror
no with uh uh with us and ourselves yeah
i mean with our sales team and with uh
and with ourselves right i i think you
can really run the gamut of 80 20 in
either direction depending on what
you're trying to accomplish
yeah what we want to accomplish we want
to create more experiences with people
we want them to connect with i
understand i'm sorry that's the micro
i'm going macro are you planning on
selling the business
no not in any time not anytime soon good
news then you have no problem
i mean this i'm going to bring this down
for you i understand everything you're
saying it's you're just talking about
pacing now
yeah
right so the answer is the answer is
both can work it just
honestly i think it comes down to what
you like more
if it's second gen and you're thinking
like not anytime soon and like
and this is where i need real answers if
you're like no gary actually i'm second
gen and i'm the guy who i want to sell
it to a pe firm in six years well that's
different if you're telling me 21 years
well that's different so like that's the
answer to your question comes from the
north star
it's why you know james you start
worships serious you know james
comes in knows exactly what he's doing
in ad land and and because i don't even
at that point i even at this point i
don't over communicate everything
running through my mind
i was doing things very differently not
because i was right or wrong or james
was right or wrong when he was my ceo
it's just that
there are not many agencies on earth
that are built being built to be built
in perpetuity
so my my appetite to not make any profit
is not in the cust that's not normal
almost every agency of any size is a
publicly traded company they have to
make numbers every 90 days let alone
every year
so all my decisions
were foreign
and and for james up front and then he
got accustomed to it and his feedback
and his vision were things that i had to
factor into hey this is his framework
that's where i'm going with you and
everybody else right now most of the
decisions all of you have to make is
what are you actually up to
like if you tell me you're trying to
sell the company in three years i'm
gonna give you very different advice if
you're trying to sustain it in
perpetuity
and how much you feel about money versus
loving it
that's it i really don't want to sell it
but i don't really want to sell in the
short term of course you know never know
what it's going to be like 10 years i
would say 20 years is a longer time
frame but we're kind of at a decision
a fair one
yeah you never know what will happen in
10 years so i definitely don't want to
be in a place where i need another 10.
yeah yeah
look i think here's what i would say
the
you don't have as big of a local base as
you think everybody makes that mistake
everybody
everyone's like man we've got this
squeezed the community loves us and now
we're going to go to toronto you never
have as much local business as you think
it's number one rule of business like
this for sure so a
if that's exciting for you
right because you're like [ __ ] we really
know how to do this we've got this model
down you can go ham and quadruple down
on it
if it's not
because you you got youthful big
ambition and conquering montreal sounds
more fun
well then you can just do that but it
won't be as financially viable as
quickly
right so we can grow and it just has to
we just have to kind of suck it up and
make sure it's you know we're going to
keep the lights on but yeah that's my
that's what i think
i'm a huge fan of
if you can live like for all of you live
as humbly as possible for as long as
possible
because that means your business is
getting more of the money
i've got a second question really quick
if possible um i just want to talk a
little bit about
strategically
i really feel like the winery game is
very traditional and there's a lot of
history and legacy behind it yeah that's
something that we
we we aren't really about all of that we
want to be kind of a new player with new
ambitions and bring it down to earth a
little bit for the average person who
maybe is
uh
you know they're interested in wine but
they feel intimidated by it we want to
kind of open up and and introduce new
people to wine so
like how do we everyone seems like in a
place especially in canada that all the
legacy players are doing the exact same
thing they're working sales funnels
they've got general content it's not
really personalized and it talks about
kind of the the prestige of wine but
how do we like what things can we do to
kind of change that game and that
narrative i mean obviously our content
but um no no no no that's it
like this is where everybody makes the
same move right like obviously our
content but what else gary none of the
content
like if you make content that shows
people pairing blueberry wine with
pancakes and you have a good time with
it people here might be interested in it
in a world where they're not interested
in it at all the reason why library tv
was so game changing in the industry was
i did it differently
it wasn't about barbing youtube ads it
wasn't about anything other than i
talked about wine differently
and you've got fruit wine like like you
should be targeting
like your content should be targeting
like
do you not like wine good news we made a
wine you'll like
like you have a whole different game
going on
you should be making content for
everybody but people that are into wine
like like like your content needs to be
about interest graph around hunting and
hockey
and
you know sledding and
do you like hot chocolate well then
you're like this like you have so much
more freedom than most people
but it's only about the content there is
nothing else on earth
it the only thing that matters is the
communication which is the content of
course there's the distribution of the
content but if you don't start with the
content i can get everybody in canada to
see your video if it's boring as [ __ ] or
not interesting it lost
so should i spend more time
on organic in that realm like the tick
tock and stuff like that or tin talk is
a dream come true it's been years since
we've had this
yeah and trying to do things maybe stay
not stay away from paid media but make
sure that the paid media's got a better
return and then and then the organic
because but you know this ios 14.5 like
there's a lot of paid media issues now
for dtc
totally this is time to lean into
creative and brand
tick tocks heaven
and everyone's lollygagging it if i mean
if you're here you're aware of me and
i've been very consistent about this and
you're all under-performing on tick-tock
and you know it
it's like it's gonna like how many times
are we going to do this all together
right like
like it's the same game and every time
it comes around
like i put out content you're like damn
i wish i found gary when instagram was
good and then tick tock comes and you're
not doing it
that
cool that's awesome thank you brother
thank you brother
all right uh we are going to move over
to jennifer down in alabama let me uh
pull you up jennifer
here we are
ajc
hey thanks for your time gary i really
appreciate it um it's a bit of
background my husband i opened real and
rosemary it's a polished fast casual
concept in birmingham in 2016. it was an
immediate success we did really well
with it in 2018 we opened a coffee shop
called caveat coffee it was also a
success later that year we opened the
second location of reel and rosemary
it'd have been slow within about six
weeks our investors decided the
restaurant wasn't going to make it which
made it really difficult to operate and
you know scrambled around
all of 2019 we retooled everything below
the sales line i had a one-year-old and
i would take her for a stroll or walk
every day and listen to your podcast
and you do wonderful social media but
also i really appreciate the operational
advice that you gave because that really
helped us navigate
when coveted hit in 2020 everything
clicked and came into focus for us uh my
husband and i are both what i would
consider wartime generals and it was
um it was great because we had already
done all the work on the brand we had
the mousetrap built so we could really
just focus on building the brand through
kobe we opened a second unit in
birmingham we just hit a year on that
one as of this week we own the company
100 all our vendors are paid we have a
cash flow positive business and i'm
forever grateful for helping us get
there
i'm getting ready in a couple weeks to
announce that we're going to open a
third location in birmingham which is
really exciting for us and we want to
continue i completely agree with what
you said we don't own enough of the
local market i'm sure it's impossible to
but we want to do more of that and then
no pun intended we have really big
appetites and we want to continue to
grow the brand across the south across
the southeast
not ready to sell it anytime soon but
maybe within the next five to seven
years if that opportunity presents
itself but we're building a brand that
we don't have to sell i understand
so one question what do you yeah what do
you want to narrow in on because that's
a great context
one of my questions to you is i've
listened to a lot of your content but i
haven't heard you talk a lot about
partners when and how you decide to
bring on a partner operationally or
financially when is that appropriate
versus going it alone
never if you can help it
yeah okay right
you know and that's been my experience
yeah
i've had some good ones but it goes back
to like what makes you happy
yeah i mean i have an offer for somebody
for one of the biggest vc firms in the
world to buy ten percent of the friends
it has my brother on the ground
in excitement and i'm not even returning
the email to set up the meeting
right and it would be a game changer for
me think about the level i'm playing at
and it would be a game-changer for me so
we're talking
real economics and my i had a meeting
with my accountant today like planning
for next year and taxes everything and
he was flabbergasted that i haven't even
reached back out in the last 30 days
it's because i kind of almost had my own
realization
it's the advice i'm giving you now which
is like i don't like it
james knows my deal with steve ross and
i only did that because aj was at a
point in his life where the money
mattered to set up his life and i didn't
want to do it i didn't
um
but like
i'm sure when james looked under the
hood it's so egregiously bad for steven
ross like they have no rights like i
could i could start a new agency by
changing all the names of the company
like it's crazy the deal they made that
was the only reason i've even had a
partner other than like family like it's
not fun
right
well that's really helpful fun but
in your business model if you want to
take in pe money or things of that
nature to expand it make it you know if
you want if you want to sell it i think
something like there are i want to go
with speed i really like the growth and
development that's what i've done the
problem is the problem is that's why i
hate speed so much i know
speed comes with compromise
yes you're going to speed yourself into
money that has control
and that's why we've tried to be patient
and we have it ourselves now and so
tagging off from that the other thing on
just on that point something you've
heard a lot from me i wish you knew how
young you were
yeah for sure no but no no before yeah
for sure like in 17 years you still have
like 35 years like you know you know
what i mean like if you can
contextualize time
yeah
i agree um
the the other thing there's a company
called clear bank
okay
so obviously the canadians shook their
heads right like there there's some
really new funding mechanisms where you
don't have to give up control that you
might want to look into right there's
also people that just want to lend money
and make interest
okay
if james is right there like the good
old-fashioned credit line and the good
old-fashioned like like we don't even
talk about getting bank loans anymore
that you pay off so you don't have to
give up your we don't even talk about
that remember everybody grew up with
that concept so there's a lot
there's a lot of other things you can
see what's going on in the chat right
now so keep that in mind as well
thank you i appreciate that i'm kind of
piggybacking off of that
we um
you know
i do believe we try to be really patient
with the restaurant and grow it the
right way and i think it does need more
time as we grow we're trying to do it
the right way but we have big brains and
big motors and we're trying to decide
how or when we should add a business um
to keep us interested so to speak versus
just focusing on the one and
particularly because we have a
location-based business kind of you know
a community
business and i feel like i'm missing out
on a lot of you know e-commerce and
these the opportunities that are really
in front right now we are in birmingham
but you know it's a big world i'm just
trying to balance this i'll give you one
that might work for you
um and it could actually work for doug
and doug thank you for the empathy in
the background um
uh
both of you could go into products that
are very viable for the things that you
know brian nihon know like you like for
example with doug's business
he should in my opinion
stand up his most signature fruit wine
and then make a fruit jam
compliment product within the brand so
he can ship that nationally and globally
yes you should do the same thing like
like for example
i i've actually
am starting a restaurant group
uh here in new york right and one of the
things i'm talking to guys about i'm
like look i don't
i'm really supporting two friends but
now that they've brought me a little bit
more in than just money i'm like look
i'm not interested in this
but if you say that we're gonna start a
restaurant that has a signature mustard
that everyone's gonna love the [ __ ]
mustard
like everyone's focused on the mustard
that i can build a 300 million direct
consumer mustard brand now i'm really
interested
so i think one of the things you can
think about is could you create a
signature condiment or
dish
in your place
that become you strictly stood up the
concept of this unique pepper just to
create a dtc pepper business
i would like to do that i think i'm
gonna work on that for sure yeah
absolutely that could be that could
scratch your big ambition creativity
muscle right you create something that
lives within your restaurant
that then can be spun out to be a global
dtc cpg brand
i just wanted to say when you started
the vcr group i reached out to david
rodelitz he's kind enough to give me
some of his time and he was amazing and
gave me some great ideas for the
business it was also encouraging seeing
you going into the restaurant business
after covert in the last year oh i love
it i i
love it i when i was saying to them i'm
not interested it wasn't because i'm not
interested it's just that they're such
experts my three partners i'm like you
don't need me to run a restaurant you
guys have done this for 74 [ __ ] years
i'll bring innovation and here's an
innovation
let's create a olive oil that we pour
for people the second they sit down with
incredible bread and let's build up the
reputation of the olive oil so that we
can then sell 100 million dollars a year
in olive oil direct to consumer
right right like the level of focus to
an olive oil that's just on the table
that's not the normal move for a
restaurant but for me that's the
innovation
all right i appreciate that thank you so
much yep let's keep it going
all right
now we're going to go over to garrett
wilhelm uh down in virginia here we go
garrett
yeah
again super thankful for your time gary
been following your content for quite a
while and can attribute some success to
that so thank you so much i'm extremely
grateful um my question is very specific
it's around uh people and it's around
scalability right so
my business is at about 1.2 million a
year
and we're ready to kind of move forward
and grow the challenging thing is is the
cost of humans has gone up
uh and so for us you know we're kind of
playing around with this idea of
bringing people up through the company
comparatively to you know paying the
higher cost for more skilled skilled
people yeah i would i would i would
spend all my energy on building an
incubator internally to create people
and retain people
yeah
that's what we think about a lot i think
the challenging thing around that is is
is for me is that human to human
training or is it something like a
tranual or something human human
human to human
you know why
the part you're gonna need is the
nuanced emotional intelligence part and
like your culture
that's exactly right i was just gonna
say how do you scale a feeling right
like you scale it through dictatorship
like just being that that ambassador of
the brand to james and joe know what
doesn't fly in my world
got it both of them have spent enough
time prior to me knowing there are
people that are talented
that they would never consider hiring
because they know if i sniffed out their
behavior which was completely
appropriate in places they used to work
that there's no shot that that person's
gonna succeed because i'm gonna smoke
them out if they don't
got it so you start with kind of your
your your mount rushmore of of people
and leadership
put your value into that and then allow
that to kind of trickle down if you will
and then you what you have to be is
never let it be compromised
right so that's exactly right comma as
you start to scale
when i'll give you an example carol is
adored by every parent
and people are signing up to your school
because of carol because she's insane
with parents and kids
but carol makes ricky and susan and
sally miserable
because she's audacious
and braggadocious
and snarky to them because they're not
carol you have to fire carol
yeah do you know how hard that is for
most businesses the scenario i just told
you
i it's a very hard thing right because
they bring in a lot of re i i see your
point exactly what i do
that is highly unusual that i'm trying
to teach the business world to do is to
not compromise on culture over finance
and that's incredibly foreign
because people have to keep the lights
on
i promise you right now for everybody
here who has employees the biggest
vulnerability in your entire company is
your weakest cultural employee
so then spending time on finding that
person poor people
creating yeah making
and creating them is the best way
you get a raw asset at 23. you have a
better chance in 25 months making them
the 25 year old version
retraining is hard
that's what i'm finding that's what i'm
finding i i come back
and you're also you're also coming and
trying to hire people from a system you
don't like
exactly i'm aware
yeah so it's you can't achieve what you
want that's right you can't achieve what
you want
yeah gary you're winning it firsthand
we've got julia balak here
straight out of school she's a good one
she's a keeper we're growing her from
the ground up
i i get it and we have a better chance
with julia than if she was you because
you came in with a lot of baggage joe
so
i'm making a joke but like joe's like
the greatest
and you and what you don't realize is
the sub
some of the teachers you're hiring
they're wonderful they don't even
realize that they're doing it
i'll i'll give you joe's it's a lot
easier
if i get julia from the beginning to be
like we're going to be vayner x centric
not client-centric
we do it our way
joe has 7 8 12 15 years of doing client
services anywhere else in the world
he subconsciously doesn't realize that
he's letting the client seep in the
dictation which ultimately becomes the
reason we lose them
yeah it's wild in my business in my
business the number one reason we lose
is because we let the client get what
they want in the short term and then
they fire us for it
i'd rather not i
because they stink
yeah and they tell you to do stink [ __ ]
and at first they love it because you're
doing what they feel comfortable with
but then they fire you because it's not
doing well
and they don't even know how to score it
amen yeah
that's what you're dealing with you're
trying to hire teachers who already
conform to the education system which
has remarkable flaws against your
hypothesis
yep and it's unlearning people rather
than teaching people which is what i'm
great
and unlearning is impossibly hard and
teaching is wildly easy
if you get them in the right state
awesome that's it
yeah thank you so much you're welcome
yeah i'm excited for you it's gonna work
thank you because what here's what it is
garrett if you like
if you now execute on what i just felt
from you in response
it becomes a religion so you waste no
time
you just don't hire from there that's it
that's it i love it shifting focus
younger
yep love it awesome
all right thanks garrett
uh next we're going to bring on brennan
and doug who want to talk about guild of
women and entities
thank you
hi so i'm going to as concisely as
possible share a bit of the history and
i'm going to hand it to doug who's going
to bring us into the future so as
mentioned we recently opened a small
luxury boutique hotel in philadelphia
the property is inside a national
historic landmark and the property was
deemed a landmark due to deep deep roots
in the women's movement so founded in
1882
a group of badass women suffragists
abolitionists one woman was a founding
member of the naacp they all gathered
here and changed the history of women
you know across the country and beyond
and
while it's very nude less than three
months old the res what we did was we've
dedicated each of the rooms to one of
these founders or women and told their
story which is largely unknown through
these rooms and suites and the response
the response has been incredible
everyone who walks through here is
really wowed by it we of course are in
love with ourselves our city is now in
love with it which we're so proud of
um but we recognize that there are many
more women both as members of the guild
and throughout the world that
really deserve light shining on them as
well which led us into this concept that
doug's going to share of uh dipping our
toes into the nft space i understand
right and essentially it's to tell that
story on on a grander scale right to
honor those women as well as give women
uh
of today
how are you gonna handle the name image
and likeness of the women if this is how
direct you're gonna go with it
handling well we're not using the actual
names in the nfts is that what you're
saying got it yeah that's where i
thought you were going to go got it no
so again we want to
we're honoring the actual women but
really what the nfts is about the women
of today right that are breaking down
doors and glass ceilings and so you know
there's a bunch of utility that i can
get into but the the to me the the
connection on
um
the women's movement
is not only the charitable donation to
the cause that still exists today right
so some proceeds will go to that um but
also the nfts essentially each owner
would be able to create their story and
have that you know on the blockchain
with their nft and so obviously it's a
male dominated space um and so our
biggest challenge is you know how do we
wait wait way less than you know
everyone likes to throw that around by
comparison web 3 is remarkably more
diverse than web 2 and one water and if
you look at the projects
i mean the female movement of whether
it's world of women or you know i've
been very active in it it's very
advanced
agreed it's very advanced there's also i
think you can see pretty easily the
women's projects that you've you know
tweeted about or whatnot and haven't
right kind of two different things uh in
terms of i think some of the results but
um for sure so they are there but i
think the thing that we're dealing with
is yes our audience is women we also
feel we need to incorporate men into
that as well and so that's also part of
um
not only the finance so not only the
financial aspect right so there'll be
income earned from owning the nft as
well we're also incorporating it with
the hotel where you can get some free
hotel stays what about income earned
because
if you go to income earned you're going
into securities
so
my understanding from the attorneys that
we've spoken with if you do it off the
mint and it goes to a separate wallet
and it goes to them directly that that's
not a security the other thing no you're
talking to very bad lawyers
okay of course it's a security just
because you're setting up a different
functionality
okay
yeah you should definitely kick into by
the way on the record i could be wrong
but [ __ ] that's not i've spent a lot of
time on this i would be surprised if
that's the case yeah so and look we come
from a finance and capital raising
background so we need to err on the side
of caution with with everything that
we're doing that's what i'm work that's
what i'm worried about
because you also don't need it
right it's not a trigger that you need
and so i just want you to
again i could be wrong because it's all
so new uh but please quadruple check
that one because that's the because
that's gonna hurt your reputation
exactly so i will we can move on from
that because like you said yeah exactly
that's not what the project is about
right what can i answer because i'm
following very easily go yeah
how do we sell out
how do we sell easy you
you stand up a discord
you produce ungodly levels of
uh twitter content
around everything that you just talked
about you have a lot more going for you
than most projects
yeah and you just launch in four months
instead of four weeks
everyone's biggest problem of why
they're not selling out is everyone's in
gold rush mode and they just want to get
their project out as quickly as possible
and then they pray to your point that i
tweet it or somebody that like me does
which is the reverse of building a
tangible real business which is build a
real community through the story i mean
the fact that you have this hotel and i
love the story right and then i wrote
something down i think you should launch
1882 tokens right because it sits right
into your narrative right yeah a little
bit less than what you can maximize in
but maybe you do that as the original
thing and then you could build a second
one but like yes
like doug i think the
by you wearing that hoodie and you guys
doing this the thing that's happening
right now brother in this space
is everyone's [ __ ] up because they
have no patience to actually spend the
four to six months to actually build a
dysport community if you build one for
four to six months you'll do quite well
otherwise you're leaving it the chance
and back to me being so involved in a
lot of female projects there's like 87
000 being built right now right it's
insane like every you know i'm getting
15 to 50
texts a day
on i'm building a female project because
they think that's the advantage it's
just not going to be
right so one question about that i don't
know if you followed women rise like
they just launched
i just hung with them yesterday in miami
so i was shocked i think they've sold
like 1500 so far i mean it seems like
they got discord the twitter they've
been doing it for a while
yep
and and that's why they're pinging me
450 times a day and even with randy
zuckerberg twice yesterday like
um
i don't think they i don't think
they built enough
she's lovely they're lovely
it's a great project one of the reasons
i'm not doing anything about it is i
can't support it just because it's been
i can't support everything right
in terms of our focus so there's look
the mission has been self-supporting
women right and so obviously we're
talking about that the other aspect that
we're looking to incorporate is finance
a financial literacy component because
one it's authentic to the history like
they set up a trust it's funded women's
projects for 140 years we're also really
passionate about financial literacy and
so whether it's an investment vehicle
which maybe it's not but incorporating
that into the message with the
self-supporting women do you feel that
could make sense or do you feel like
it's trying to serve two two different
things
i think you're looking i i love the way
you ask the question directly and all
your behavior matches your question
which is what i love the focus i think
you're
looking for the triggers to create
success
and the reason you're surprised by rise
is it's
not about
the literature like it's not about the
altruism
well right it's not
it's about it's about
the variables of like first of all 90 of
the people in the space buying nfts are
buying it with the thought that they're
going to make a profit
right right so you're in a you're in a
very unique spot where first of all i
think at any second the whole thing
could have a massive collapse like
internet stocks in 2000
two
nobody's building meaningful like like
like
everything that worked in may and march
and april is dead already those were the
first mover advantage that's just not
how it works you know real estate sorry
you didn't buy beachfront property
that's done now so you know now you got
to decide if this is going to be malibu
or malibu because if it's going to be
shmalibu you're not going to buy the
fourth street off the beach if it's
going to be malibu good news you're
going to [ __ ] crush you have to
decide that and then number two
i think you have to build this is why
i'm in such a good place you have to
build on actual community which you have
none of yet digitally which is okay you
gotta start you know you're gonna start
to and two you've gotta build on content
like you've gotta make and the good news
is the game is very well laid out it is
a twitter and discord game yeah dominate
twitter and discord for six months and
then launch your project
that gives you an incredible chance of
success
why is everybody not doing that because
everybody doesn't know when the whole
thing's gonna stop and sort of trying to
get out as fast as possible get as much
ethereum in their wallet as possible
yeah
so
last thing on that so on the
nft or the crypto front like i'm the one
that's driving that right we've got
amazing women like brennan our artist
you know everyone else is female but i
feel like i'm the one like
i mean i can't be the best part
yeah
um
i don't i have a concern about that and
maybe i should just put that to the side
or trying to figure out transparency
always works
you gotta you know just cause you're one
of the team members like boys can help
girls
right
okay
i i again i'm very excited because what
i'm hearing is
somebody who really knows what's going
on in nft land you
but i think it's trapping you into all
the wrong things
it's why i'm so pushing against the
space right now you're on it
you're on it
the problem is the on it right now are
doing the wrong things and the whole
thing's gonna [ __ ]
that's why there's going to be a crash
the behavior is
way too short-term
way too like it's not in the depth
we're in the sizzle phase it's the gold
rush
this is 1800 whatever the [ __ ] it was
and everyone's and everybody on the east
coast is saying you got to get to l.a
everyone makes money they're just gold
the problem is it's not going to work
out
like you've got to do the real stuff you
need to build a community for six months
and then you'll sell out otherwise you
might not
or you can get lucky and somebody that
influences sales does it
all right sounds good
i don't think you should by the way you
should definitely not hide as a team
member
no ah
i'm not hiding as a team member i think
you could be you could just because you
can speak about nfts better than brett
and your artist doesn't mean that that's
going to undermine the female nature of
the project
the truth is the truth of the truth of
what you're doing
right
okay and uh on a side note maybe some
way
we uh we created a uh an honorary member
guild of women um for you um of your mom
so we'd love to get them
thank you thank you
thank you gary thank you
awesome we're going to bring on the
simons
so
um
aaron and elizabeth say hi
hello gary
hi hi
i don't know where you went on the
screen oh there you are all right it
moves around every time so when we when
we started you remember uh swanky sauce
with vaynersports
you started uh oh my gosh we started
that back in 2012 based on your um
regret his poison kind of thing and it
was just a passion project we did it
awesome it's been going we sell a couple
thousand bottles of barbecue sauce a
year nothing crazy yep and we started a
youtube channel actually my wife started
it how-to videos about goats we own a
goat farm right how to do this how to do
that
and then to make a long story short i
started vlogging
the family everything for kids living on
this farm running the barbecue sauce
business and then we had some stupid
idea of going live 24 7.
and that's what we do now we have two
barns four cameras
it's all
ridiculous pretty much but it's two
live cams all the time on youtube one
stays still all the time really it's
really not i mean you know this it
wasn't a stupid idea you've seen other
executions of this work so you were
smart i think it's the furthest thing
from a stupid idea but go ahead yeah so
so then the stupid part well the part we
didn't realize and that's what won't get
into the question here is the community
that we built and how close we have
gotten to them and how close they have
gotten to us half this stuff you see
behind us was sent here from our
community that's awesome because i'm a
dnf student i'm going to let my wife
read the questions i get it
yeah so i mean it really kind of
originated back in 2009 when we wanted a
source of fresh eggs for our growing
family at the time we had two young boys
and we knew that grocery store food
wasn't exactly the healthiest well you
wanted to put it in here
and so we started with chickens turns
out chickens are the gateway livestock
animal and so we had to naturally
upgrade and we got ourselves into goats
mainly because i felt cows were a little
too big and to manage around a young
family
um so we got into goats for the milk and
then my kids started showing them and
really creating that bond with their
animals
and um
to your point we started the youtube
channel so that i could teach kind of
how to or how we do because it's not you
ask 10 different farmers how they raise
their goats you're going to get 12
different answers
um so we started that
as sort of my new year's resolution in
2018 by 2019 kidding season rolling
around it was actually out of
convenience that we started to live
stream because it was becoming too hard
to access
yeah
make sense documenting and having to go
in and edit all that
so we just live streamed it and we would
take the camera off the wall for the for
the community and we it was like you're
having a birthday i totally totally
totally totally get it as you know yeah
so fast forward during one of our q and
a's that we were doing and our community
actually was asking us well what can we
buy that we can have a piece of your
makes sense and so i had dabbled in some
lotion
and
you know a month or two later we were
taking hundreds of pre-orders and having
to upgrade our manufacturing facility
and um and then in 2020 he got laid off
from his day job but we had a foundation
and all we were able to do you know 2018
we had a
gross income of 30 000 it was really
just a hobby that helped pay for the hay
bill um this year we're looking to um
gross over 250 000.
and um
we have like i said we really go into
the quality of our products is what what
our brand is about people have learned
to expect a certain quality of course
and and it's there um so of course it's
that it's at the size and scale where it
can be extreme quality exactly
so i guess a couple of our questions
because our quality is what it is i am
not willing to budge on
on our quality i have a hard time
delegating to other people um and we
don't have any real employees yet we
have some friends and family that help
us
but to take some stuff off of my plate
and off of his plate we kind of delegate
some of these projects that i have a
hard time honestly delegating
um
and it's because when i get the
quality of work back i'm like
i should have just done this myself so
on a scalability issue as we're growing
how
how do i continue to ensure that the
quality is there but
be able to delegate and by by letting
the person that should be judging a
judge
so let the customer judge it
yes those people
because because
you may lose 17 customers when that
batch went wrong but then you'll adjust
but at this point you're going nowhere
right this is how i took my dad's
business from three to 65 million he
wanted to do everything i said let the
customer decide this is deja vu for me
yeah yeah
you know what you learned
no that's again thinking you're thinking
too much defense
yeah
you're so focused on that part
that part's easy to your point you'll
find out at one second about that you're
you're
you're compromising
on ego
believe it or not
ego's hurting you i make this better and
it's coming from a good place it's you
know sometimes he goes a bad word but
like it's not that bad but it is what's
happening here
yeah i i have a news alert for you many
many many many people on earth can do it
too yep yeah oh yeah okay good find them
well that's that that leads me to my
next question
um because we are
18 months into this real like putting
fuel on a fire um and we're sitting at
250 gross sales um but we haven't
actually paid ourselves yet so how do we
you know with reinvesting constantly
back into the business to grow at the
speed that we're growing at
we can't afford an employee
um
gotten there yet yeah i mean i think uh
there's a lot of ways to think about
this one
are you selling it for enough margin
i believe so yeah yeah our soaps were
selling at about an
86 margin
um what's wrong with 300
that would put us i mean well so we're
already for goat milk um soap
industry standard is you know even on
the high end is about a dollar fifty an
ounce okay and i believe we're already
at you would know the numbers oh we're
up in the two dollars range um and same
goes for our goat milk lotion but to
gary's point and i'm just going to show
because it's easier we've launched very
simple soap right seven dollars a bar
and then to my wife's point we're up in
the 15 a bar so when you get into the
fancy you know holiday stuff you know
and and 15
for a bar of soap in the soap world is
high but we look at it as artwork that
happens to be in soap
and to be honest we sell out of a lot of
it
i just don't think 20 can be justified
15 couldn't be justified if you were
talking about it at 12.
right
yeah and we were at 12 and we went to
15.
and we just did a five dollar increase
per bottle of lotion we were at 15 now
we're at 20. and i mean i i
you talk about the big guys with the
beekman um lotions
price per ounce were even higher than
they are
right but we're still selling out
yeah i mean
you've not figured out your price ss
like upside right you just
you're not going to be able to hire
somebody
if you're
not making enough margin against what
how you're reinvesting back in you're
gonna have to figure this out yeah so
i'm just gonna i don't think based on
the margin i don't think that's it
because where all the money's going is
actually not into the soap and the
lotion it's going into other products
behind the brand like the custom stuffed
animal of one of our goats our audience
is excited about this they love it but
it's stuck in a shipping container in
l.a based on the current code that yeah
that's that's that's where that is yeah
that's just small business mismanagement
of cash flow like you should have
pre-sold the toy yeah well we were told
to well well we were told to and we were
told not to
um because well you were you were
totally not right though because think
about what's happening like think about
this conversation
yeah yeah
you know like i think the you know the
reality is is that when you're in a cash
flow crunch outlaying
money is always a bad idea
right
yep and what you could have done is
created perceived value how much are you
selling the stuffed animal for 30 that's
gonna go for 40. great so you could have
sold it for 36 on pre-sale and 44.99
when it got here which would have
created urgency and
savings yeah so that just comes down to
a logistic issue we tried to pre-sale
once before and shopify was a mess and
we were like oh my gosh no pre-sales
anymore so that just that's an
ideological mistake like maybe there's
been technology advancements maybe
there's a new shopify plug-in that's
changing you know like you made an
ideological point of view yeah yeah
and what you've done is you've created a
financial cash flow crunch which is the
the number one rule of your business and
the number two and three rule is manage
your cash flow when you're this small
right
no
which if we managed it or pre-sold those
or we even have a book we just launched
uh that happened to show up about a week
before we thought it was going to so we
watched it
what's that what is that bad or no that
was good we oh that was great because it
then opened up you know more cash flow
more yeah you guys you guys
basically need to do 80 of the thing
that's working
maximize the [ __ ] out of it it sounds
like you just did with raising your
prices
80 percent of your energy needs to go
there and you guys are such
entrepreneurs and creatives
that you're getting caught up in the
other stuff which is amazing but when
you do that stuff
max 30 of your energy my preference 20
of your energy every time you do a
[ __ ] book or a stuffed animal or
whatever the [ __ ] else you're gonna come
up with in a week you always pre-sell it
okay
you have a rabid community that trusts
you right so we have other products we
want to launch so you're good good news
all this creative entrepreneurial juice
you have from dnf student dna you can
launch them all but i want you to
pre-sell every one of them should i kick
starter them no because we thought of
that too no just
that's just a tactical slight difference
that doesn't mean anything
it doesn't mean anything all right so
one of the one of them it sounds like
you need to google if there's a better
plug-in for pre-sales on shopify i do
and you know it and to your point it was
short-term we needed that cash
um
we didn't you made it you made a
strategic decision to make something and
you needed you needed this strategy
right before it to make that thing right
yeah right it was yeah so once you have
the yeah
yeah so we do um
subscription based um products as well
and one of those is actually a
subscription based to our live chat so
we moved away from a volunteer moderator
chat on our live streams and moved
towards a membership
um platform that youtube provides where
only people who are subscribers and
um
and pay us a monthly fee
anybody can watch it's free
i got it i got it
right what would you suggest um
to
grow that membership
on our like on our channels nothing
it's a it's a very aggressive ask
yeah it is and it's all and we said it
only at 1.99 but to your point it's
still like why am i going to pay to chat
yeah yeah and the only reason we did
that is because the trolls and the
because we're live 24 7 we can't watch
it 24 7. and people were coming in
talking
it just got ugly i understand but it's
hurting you more than you think
yeah no
yeah from a financial side it's hurting
but no no from a brand perception it
seems like you're trying to monetize too
much on your audience i promise that's a
very aggressive ask yeah
yeah i really believe that
okay
it works it can work but you want to
think that through
yeah
yeah what it did help us with though was
um save the continuity of
the environment i understand that i
understood that
i get it it was definitely you could
also you could also ban people
oh we have about 4 000 banned already
yeah you also if you have that many band
i'm also curious what you banned people
for
yeah well we had a we had a distrust in
our moderators is what happened so we
had to instead of just getting rid of
one we had to get rid of them all
and then create a new model and that's
what we did we actually went dark for 48
hours and got hate mail because we shut
them down yeah um to try to solve all
this
yeah i think i think i understand again
again i think that
business is about strategy yeah you you
know whatever drama was going on with
your mods
i love the idea of cleaning the deck but
you could also build back i mean now
that you've paid people you've got
perfect people to decide to be the mods
yeah you know like so
yeah yeah we have to we actually put
that idea out there that like we might
go back to moderators we might go i
think you should i don't i don't like
the dot i don't for the wholesomeness
of what you're doing the dollar 99 to
talk thing is an egregious ask i think
yeah
i get the value of the cleanup but that
you do with mods
yeah so i'll shift gears while you look
at a different question back to your
tick tock please don't look at mine
um i won't
yeah well
it's that push-up thing i do it every
other day or every once in a while but
really i'm trying to do the document
don't create model on tick tock and it
doesn't seem to be working good do
something else
okay so it's the most important thing
that you can focus your thing could go
banana [ __ ] on tick tock
yeah we get like 100 views on all of
them and then one pops at 40 thousand
and then a hundred and okay how many
posts a day one every three days that's
not even it's like once every three four
a week yeah
yeah three a day
got it figure it out
yeah all right i don't want to run out
of time i know we got one or two more
thank you
and i love the conversations going on
jennifer thank you so so much for
offering to help with cash flow for some
of our lovely 40s customers i'm sure
some of these folks will take you up on
it particularly neha who's very active
in the community right now uh neha and
brian uh you're the last folks on with
garyvee today so uh we're gonna go out
with a bang
okay great thanks um i'll do a quick
intro and then throw to neha for the
question
um
gary as we said online retail d2c
specialty food
highly curated so we're not the 5000 sku
hope you find something you like we're
three to four hundred skus
the only things we sell are what lasts
in our team's kitchen
if they don't like it doesn't last in
our kitchen well
we don't want to sell it and yeah i
think that's that's a quick intro so
i'll throw it to neja
can you hear me
awesome so
gary we've relied on the brands that we
carry to build our own brand i get it so
what we're now looking to do is
it's like wine library right like you
carry wines
but you made empathy later so we're kind
of at this juncture where we're how do
we build our own brand as a retail store
uh the brand or or actual brands
like private labels but maybe not named
directly after your retail store but
other brands that that's one way to do
it because four days ago you did tell
another retailer to do this
but i have four
five quick ideas i'm just gonna pitch
them to you really fast yep one size
does matter so we're the retailer that's
figured out how to ship in the smallest
[ __ ] box possible like really really
small
two
podcast where we interview uh
suppliers people in the cpg about the
one biggest mistake they made building a
food brand
why do you want to do that as the
creative because it's because that's a
b2b show it is so you're using that to
acquire more products for your store
absolutely okay
three that is that a need
you know it doesn't sound like the
biggest need of the organization is
more
products
right because given all the headaches
sometimes a challenge right you have
such a moat with how much of the pain of
the ass it is to get into canada that i
feel like you're building another moat
that takes a lot of effort the podcast
on something you already have a moat for
and you only have so much energy and
time and resources
yeah
which is why we haven't done it yet
we've talked about it six months got it
gotta go keep going but
understood
we're a team of five and a favorite
number uh
storytelling the the challenges of the
food industry on tiktok
so some of our suppliers are just
shutting down like small food brands
they just can't compete costco's private
labeling them or just building their own
you know product or knocking off a jam
or whatever the case is
well what does that have to do with you
though it does because
it is
what we do is all of the brands we carry
are small to mid-sized brands who are
bypassing the traditional joker
distributor channel
but the end customer doesn't understand
that right so
what
they don't understand the food
the trajectory of like how difficult it
is for a small to mid-size food ban to
survive they don't care
what the [ __ ] would a customer care
about that for
don't try to sell food on altruism
i don't think it's altruism i think it's
something that's interesting which is
like really not
but what if i do a tick tock like
basically presenting to a large retailer
as a brand and how difficult it is the
worst terrible so interesting that
you're saying that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about what you just said people care
about if the jam looks good when you put
it on the bagel and then they just buy
the jam
you're too nerdy right now
you're you're making [ __ ] that you find
interesting and i find i do i know you
do i'm watching you do it in real time
right yeah that's why i'm giving you the
answer i'm here to help you you spent
money today i'm gonna make you money
like you're making content that nobody
gives a [ __ ] about
okay you need to make contact like you
the supermarket like wine library forget
about empathy my library exploded
because i did things to build wine
library which then gave me customers
which then gave me leverage for my
suppliers
you need to become the co you've been
relying on the exclusivity and they've
been driving your business you need to
be the driver of your business
thus you have to make content that's
interesting to consumers
like you need to make viral peanut
butter content for the brand you decided
to sell peanut butter for
but that's still focusing on the brand
right so okay yes but you're the you're
the you're the platform that that's
being done on them like sure i might be
like this peanut butter's super gooey
and then i do something that makes 800
000 people watch it but it's still being
delivered from your company
like whole foods markets like ulta
markets sephora markets like costco like
you like
you have to become the marketer and you
have to be consumer marketing using your
products that you're selling and yes
sure you can integrate your own private
labels over time but you still need to
make content around like
because what that's going to do is give
you double leverage you're going to make
product that sells better but even
better than that now you're providing
you know
demand for brands which is going to
bring more brands to you right now
you're a value prop from a logistics
standpoint but they're driving your
business
okay
a tv show where we taste test our
products
i like to do it on tick tock first
say talk first okay i mean especially
you because you have charisma like
literally you tasting [ __ ] and just
talking yeah
tick-tock we watched wine library
episode one last night very different
than episode 86
and i just thought
you know what that is by the way and why
i know those two numbers
yeah i was scared to lose my clients
yeah first 86 episodes people forget
wine library was already a huge business
before wine library tv
so i realized all those serious people
that lived in short hills in livingston
and worked on wall street and bankers
that if i was fully me that i was gonna
lose them
so i was scared but then the show was
doing so well and i was like man i'm not
even [ __ ]
being myself i and i got to a place
where i was like oh this is really gonna
work so i felt comfortable of like going
all in
and so
yeah
okay
i love it i'm actually i'm really
excited about that um i think you would
be i think you'd be fantastic
okay thank you but just remember in
between like gary episode one and what
gary is today is where i see you and
just be you don't try to be with any
version of anything just be you
yeah yeah i agree um private label yes
so you've talked about this a lot and
then the food so right now our margins
are you know structured they are what
they are
yeah private label is immensely
important to you but i wouldn't do it
like kirkland where you have like a
brand or i wouldn't do it under your
store brand i would make up brands
that's what did really well for me at
wine like like whatever what's your
favorite animal
so a monkey
actually a lion a lion a lion
what's what's a category that you think
you could do more business in or
something that you don't have great
brands with or somewhere where you're
doing business but you don't love your
margin
condiments
like mustard barbecue sauce good
barbecue sauce make a legendary lion
barbecue sauce right away
so so on that because typically private
label for food is it's your basic
staples
and that's we've never want to do that
because that's
i don't want to compete on basic
flour i think there's tons of like
premium like there's a lot of comp
stores to what you do that are in the
upper premium level that have plenty of
private labels that are like and what
the holy grail is is if you stumble into
pay dirt and like another nice uh
canadian company uh moose knuckle where
they created a private label in their
own store and then that became the
actual business that gets real fun could
you imagine you sell lion barbecue sauce
to craft for 48 million dollars
that's what can happen to retailers
yeah so focus on like a premium innovate
like you're doing both right you're
doing both
that's exactly right but create our own
okay but what's nice about that is you
get to reverse engineer the white spaces
of your retail store
right so you just said condiments we'd
like to make more margin that sounds
good uh there's a new trend and
everyone's into honey toast whatever the
[ __ ] that would be then now you can make
one quickly in that space
so the follow-up to that gary is
[ __ ] money
money
right so
right you want to take that
well and so this is the challenge in my
other cfo job i go raise money for
startups
that's what i do we don't we haven't
done that for our company
but it's the
in a product business like doing a
private label cash flow intensive
um
if you were gonna do how many active
customers do you guys have
ten thousand ten thousand
somewhere in there nice um
yeah look again
a lot of canada themes like
i think clear bank is a really
interesting model
that's one yeah we work with them
um there's that
number two there's raising capital which
we've talked about in different versions
but you might have different feelings
per se than jennifer or you know or me
or what have you so that's number two
number three
is like we talked about with
with our friends in the connecticut goat
life like i'm a humongous believer in
pre-sale
it works when you have trust
it's like cashing in on trust you've
done all the right things everybody here
is honorable good people delivering
trying hard like right like that's trust
trust can be monetized in pre-sale
you'll deliver and then you'll have more
trust
my dad didn't my dad didn't have cash
flow for [ __ ]
pre-sales selling wine futures saved my
dad's business
which is why we were just thinking
yesterday we were like the 3 million to
60 for wine library
it's hard to scale that without any debt
and just solely out of the profits of
the company right yeah it's why i went
on to become gary vee like i ended up
being like what i didn't know at the
time was like i was gonna be an all-time
good businessman
you want to hear something scarier wine
library did 3.8 million on 10 gross
profit
oh
yeah you want some real seat you want
some real cfo talk here we go 3.8
380 000 in sales
before your expenses
oh
and i grew that from 3.8 to 65 in seven
years with no credit line
like my st i'm underrated
because i know you know you know why i'm
underrated because i never go all the
way there because i think it because i
don't want to make it seem like my dad
like it's kind of like a family thing
yeah for sure like right but 3.8
10 gross profit
no credit line
yeah i've worked with a lot of companies
who have those margins and they shove a
ton of debt into the company to fund the
growth zero so that's impressive but i
did it through all the advice i'm giving
now right creating high margin items
um pre-saleing
you know i also look i i say it but like
i had a lot of juice right i was working
17 hours a day i had the talent like
there's a lot go going on there but
that's what happened and so like not
that i expect that from everybody but
the nuances work priest
i'm not [ __ ] making stuffed animals
that can get caught up in la like we
need to pre-sell that [ __ ] down in
connecticut you know that's it
70 on what's working [ __ ] squeeze the
[ __ ] out of it because you got something
good there and you could [ __ ] have
nothing but fun aaron like with whatever
creative idea you have but
here's the rule for your [ __ ] dnf
charisma and creativity like me it's
only pre-sell any cockmanian [ __ ] out of
your mouth is only pre-sell
and if you sell seven by the way you
also make a lot more money when you
pre-sell you guessed how many [ __ ]
stuffed animals to make
on pre-sale you're like oh [ __ ] we can
make more
you know and when you when you price it
with worst case scenario we only sell 50
of them this is how much it costs now
let's say you sell 530 you get a cheaper
like the whole thing works
we're good gary can we get a photo of
you like just smiling or not smiling at
him
okay okay
three two one
love it thank you
that was great
team listen this was a really epic
session because it was sharp i think i
don't know i was in a good mood or
something or sharp or it just all worked
out for like [ __ ] that i've been a lot
of like actually now i'm looking around
it's just because i've been doing
everything that like i'm very tied into
this crew we have like a lot going on
here listen there's a couple themes i
want to leave you with
first
start falling in love with pre-sale
because it can really help you
start like really thinking about that
two
if you do not go ham on tick-tock
content
you will be making such a regretful
moment because we've got two more years
of this and then it's gonna go away
it's gonna go away
right and so like i saw somebody
referenced with the new apple updates
getting read like [ __ ] changes tick
tock's gonna get saturated because
everyone's gonna figure out what i know
and it's just supply and demand of the
feed
and
and really really building that
community stuff like building like
doug for you like if you guys can just
hold your breath for four months and
actually build a discord you'll win
you'll mitigate all the other chants out
but you have to do it like building
communities
really mattered obviously
the simons know that because that's what
they're built on the community can
really work for you like uh discord's a
sneaky one it's winning so big in video
games and in nfts i actually think it's
gonna go to everything so one left field
thing for all of you if doug stands up a
discord at first a lot of people aren't
gonna his his core customer race isn't
really gonna know what that is but it's
so native to people because it's old aol
chat room dna
so like even like people that aren't
technically awesome very quickly get
comfortable inside of discord we're
thinking about
definitely worth you jumping into some
discords join the v friends one just so
you understand it
right actually that's what i'm gonna put
that link in here all of you should
definitely back to more like actions
instead of just talking about it here is
the
v friends discord join it see how
discord get comfortable just download
the app like get comfortable for you and
then
i think it can really work for you like
for example if garrett starts a
you know young parents
of virginia discord runs facebook ads
against young people like young parent
age on facebook ads to a discord not to
sign think about how much easier the ad
will convert to join a discord versus do
you want to pay a thousand dollars in
tuition now you got him in a discord you
live in there and cultivate a community
now you're getting them in for 49 to 7
you see 49 cents to seven dollars into
the discord but
you're [ __ ] converting them after two
months when they realize there's
something really in there got it
great time bye everyone this portion is
like with me so i think this is when you
need to get selfish like you need to ask
your question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]
you